At least 22 people have died and reports say
a dozen are missing in southern India after
heavy rains caused flash floods and landslides.
The Indian Army has sent teams to help the
rescue operation in the coastal state of Kerala.
Thousands of people have been forced from
their homes.
The Kerala state government says over a hundred
relief camps have been set up.
A human chain passes the bodies pulled from
the mud.
The heavy rains in the Indian state of Kerala
started on Friday and caused landslides.
Forcing thousands to flee to safety as the
mudslides swallowed homes and loved ones.
"The hill broke off near us.
There has been a lot of damage and loss.
The house has gone.
Children have gone.
All that has happened.
The water entered our homes - that’s when
they moved us."
The Indian Airforce had to use helicopters
to reach some affected areas which were cut
off completely by road.
Swollen rivers, swept away houses, built too
close to their banks.
Building and development over wetland and
forest areas has made the state more vulnerable
to flooding.
And as waters subsided, local people were
distraught at the damage.
"It was my livelihood.
Everything is gone.
Look everything is gone."
In another town nearby, a shopkeeper struggled
to salvage what he could from his spoiled
goods.
"We managed to save some vegetables like onions
but most of our vegetables have been destroyed."
The Indian government has deployed the military
to help with the relief operations and promised
to provide all possible support to help people
in need.